Dlive is a livestreaming platform
created to empower creators and reward viewers
tHAT'S YOU
I've been streaming on dlive for a month now
and its been absolutely fantastic
Everyone in the community has been so welcoming
'okay, alright alright'
It's been nothing but smiles and laughs
I love how everyone in the community is so excited about the platform
and getting other people into it as well so i definitely recommend that you're streaming on dlive
Now for you, the viewer
dlive is rewarding you more than ever before baby
Other platforms, pshh, they just spam a bunch of ads
Very anti-viewer
dlive, completely opposite, very welcome viewer
dlive rewards you simply for watching
Simply for chatting, simply for supporting streamers
dlive is launching a brand new treasure chest
Now how does this treasure chest work you might ask?
The more viewers engage, chat and donate
the faster you will unlock the chest
and the faster that chest gets burst baby
the more viewers will be rewarded
To show my appreciation, my deep and utmost...
Love <3
I'll be streaming on May 18th
And let's burst some chests baby
This is during the dlive Super fans festival
To celebrate you guys
Download the dlive app now, and I'll see you guys on May 18th
I think it's been really fun to,
engage live with you guys
It's bringing in a whole new perspective and idea so
Thanks for everyone that joined me so far
Now lets just get on with the video
i broke my balls
That's right everyone
It's time for me to finally come clean
and share one of my most embarrassing stories of my life
And you might think to yourself
'oh i broken my balls too'
'it really hurts when you smash them ohhh i got kicked in my balls '
thats NOTHING
tHAS NOTHING
sorry
Now technically i didn't break my balls
I just need the titles to be consistent
But lemme tell you what happened, and it might change your mind
it might make you go
oOF
I don't know what pain is, what that man experienced, that was pain
He didn't just break his ass
He also broke his balls
and he broke my heart
by listening to this story
so lets just jump into it
I was 14 years old
and i woke up
and did what anyone that has balls do when they wake up
you look- You look at them
I looked down at my balls and i noticed
hMM
'that's a bit weird'
the other one is like three times
four times maybe
larger than the other one
'hmm that's a bit weird'
But of course
i didn't think about it more than that
Why should I?
But then as the day went on
It was sort of lingering in the back of my mind
'you know what, maybe it isn't supposed to be so much bigger'
'has it always been that much bigger?'
'Maybe i just never noticed'
Maybe im- just some girls have different proportionate boobies
Maybe I'm a disproportionate ball kinda guy
Its not great news
Its not what you wanna wake up realising
but that's what i thought at least
But then
After a while I realized I need to confront this.
This is not normal.
Okay.
So I did what any person would have done if there's something wrong with your balls:
You show them to your dad.
And obviously that's very humiliating already.
You don't want to show your balls to your dad.
At least I don't, okay?
I think the only context you're allowed to show your balls to your dad is...
in the sauna.
And...
No, I think that's it. That's the only context.
Or if your ball is bigger than the other one, of course.
So I showed my– I was freaking out, okay?
I was super worried about what was wrong with me.
You know worst possible scenarios is running in your head.
Not like oh do I have cancer or Oh, am I good something really bad happened. It was oh my god
Am I gonna live with this proportion that balls my entire life? I was freaking out
I showed my balls to my dad and he you know
Whenever you're worried about something the most reassuring thing that you can
Get back from someone is obviously when they make this face
Hey, Dad, can you please look at my balls please? And make sure it's nothing bad, right?
I'll never forget that face worse than any disappointment realize my camera isn't really focused
So obviously he didn't think it was fine
What am I sharing this?
so we we booked an appointment with the doctor and
I think they let us in pretty quickly. I don't know if that's health care in Sweden
It's good or if they thought oh like oh, that's not that's really bad
Well, we'll need to get this guy into the hospital
But I remember this hospital visit unfortunately
Very very very clearly because it was painful a very painful experience. I basically had to
Go into this room
And I remembered so clearly they had like brown
Tiles and white walls just like hard surfaces everywhere
And there was this bed in the middle of the room that it wasn't really, you know
Like those hospital beds then you lay down on kind of like this just imagine 14 or all mean like this. Okay
I'm laying down like this
I'm freaking out
my dad is sitting next to me and in comes this doctor and
The thing is like that what really bothers me about these things is that no one tells you what the courtesy is
You know in school they teach you about math. They teach you by a history
They teach you about science all these completely useless things
But no one teaches you what to do when you have to present your balls to a doctor
All right
here's a question that no one teaches you in school when you're supposed to present your balls to someone do you give them the
courtesy of
lifting up your song
It would make sense, right
I remember going I remember God watch my sharing that and hidden the doctor just going on
Put that away. Let me get in there. So he started croaking. I'm alone
And obviously that's not a very good feeling. I'm already humiliated and I had this guy just going
Treating my boss like it's some sort of
Thing that you poke I don't know what kind of things do you poke?
But he wasn't sure I guess he really wanted to make sure it wasn't something really bad
So he wanted some expertise his help and I'm pretty sure he knew it was fine
Okay, because I'm pretty sure he just wanted to humiliate me even farther
so not just two more doctors came in three more doctors came in and one of them happened to be a very
attractive lady
which is like the worst thing you could ever have to someone just poking or just looking I would rather like she poked and just
Looked so there I was in this cold room with my dad next to me and I assumed they was equally painful for him
Just think doctors poking away now they concluded
Okay, we need to get the Bulls and so I got an appointment about a week later again
Same dilemma this time. I was alone. My dad wasn't with me. I wish it was honestly for the better
There was no doctor in the room when I was sent in there as well
So and I know he's gonna check out my balls. So again, no one teaches in this school
Am I supposed to just take off my pants and wait for him pay less and be like, hey, I'm ready doctor
Or do I wait to take off my pants? I took off my pants and I realized that's really weird
Can you imagine just coming in and some oh, hey doctor. I'm ready poked away this time
They just used some sort of scanner. I don't know exactly what it was
It wasn't that it wasn't painful at all this time
Maybe it's one of those experiences that once you've done it once it's not that bad. I
Like to think of it that way at least link what doesn't kill you make you stronger
at least now if someone needs to inspect my balls, I
Can I can do it proudly, but they concluded it was just my blood vessel in my balls
Had expanded dad-like became larger
So that was it. That's the story of how my balls are slightly larger than average
Nobody baby boy now. I want the moral of this story to be
You know, this is obviously a very embarrassing experience, but I also consider myself very lucky to have balls
I think anyone that I have balls feel very privileged to have them
Not that then I'm not discriminating against anyone without balls. Just let that be clear
I'm just saying I'm very happy to have my balls. What was the point of this video? I'm very lucky to have balls
I'm very lucky to have my point. I'm very lucky to be healthy, but I'm not discriminating against anyone
okay, and also as some painful and embarrassing this experience once it's something that I can look back at and laugh at and
Not just cringe into oblivion
So if you have any issues with your balls go and get your balls checked go show your balls to your dad
Anything you got to do just do it because it's better to find out, you know, I was lucky that it was nothing
But it's better to find out these things sooner and if there's any message I want to send out there it is
That just that show your balls to your dad. That's really the only message of this video and I really hope this helps people
I'm doing this so I can help other people
I've actually had my balls checked three times, which is three times too many
No, four times
Why does these things happen to me? Was breaking my ass not enough
I think I shared enough about this experience. But I do feel better. I gotta say this is very therapetic
"Thearapeutic" for me. Thank you for listening and I see you next time
That's the story of how my balls are slightly larger than average
What you never played toupper simulator
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not. Not convinced yet? Okay, I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price.